in china ist ein hochgefährlicher
superplus entdeckt worden
dieser bakterienstamm vereint die
schlimmsten eigenschaften die solche
super bazillen nur haben können er ist
resistent gegen alle bekannten
antibiotika also einer der berüchtigten
multiresistenten krankenhauskeime und
dazu ist er auch noch hoch ansteckend
und zudem tödlich wenn dieser
bakterienstamm sich ausbreitet haben wer
eine weltweite epidemie eine pandemie
droht jetzt also bald eine pandemie oder
ist das alles nur wieder panikmache
jetzt sind klick zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen klickst du um hatte
als eines der ersten medien in
deutschland über den ebola ausbruch in
afrika berichtet und als einziges medium
die entwicklung auch kontinuierlich
weiterverfolgt während andere
sensationsgierigen publikationen schnell
die lust verloren bisher gab es ja immer
nur ein paar tote durch ebola konnte nur
bei uns der verlauf der epidemie
kontinuierlich verfolgt werden und ich
möchte hier noch mal eine lanze für
uns brechen nur hierbei klicks und das
war wirklich so war dann auch
frühzeitig zu erkennen welch
verheerende entwicklung die solche namen
und sich zur größten ebola epidemie
aller zeiten entwickelt hat mehr als
28.000 menschen erkranken an ebola und
mit mehr als 11.000 starben fast die
hälfte der infizierten
zwischenzeitlich drohte die epidemie
vollkommen außer kontrolle zu geraten
als immer mehr menschen immer schneller
infiziert wurden
die weltgesundheitsorganisation whu rief
zum dritten mal in der geschichte der
menschheit den internationalen
gesundheitsnotfall aus und ließ den
einsatz nicht zugelassener und nur wenig
getesteter medikamente zu während schon
die ersten infizierten begann das virus
in den usa und europa zu verbreiten
konnte durch den einsatz der medikamente
und massiv durchgesetzt die situation
der erkrankten das virus gestoppt werden
es war knapp
was uns jetzt vielleicht droht könnte
schneller gehen und viel gefährlicher
sein denn was chinesische
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
jetzt im fachmagazin the lancet
beschreiben ist absolut alarmierend
bisher ist dieser super bazillus nur in
einem krankenhaus entdeckt worden und
bisher auf dieses krankenhaus
beschränkt aber mehrere
begleitumstände und die eigenschaften
und der verlauf der infektion
sie sind beunruhigen zitat der tödliche
ausbruch geschah in einer brandneuen
klinik zitiert die webseite npr
forschungsleiter schenken
antibiotikaresistente keime hätten gar
nicht so schnell entstehen sollen
fünf patienten hatten sich über
beatmungsgeräte auf der intensivstation
infiziert alle starben kurz darauf so
tragisch es auch ist solche infektionen
sind in krankenhäusern keine seltenheit
doch die forschungsgruppe fand
alarmierendes über den neuen km heraus
er ist eine mutation von klebsiella
pneumoniae ein bazillus der bereits als
multiresistent bekannt ist nichts hilft
gegen diese bakterien im september starb
eine frau in den usa an diesem bazillus
alle 26 zugelassenen antibiotika hat
nicht gewirkt die bakterie war gegen
alle resistent angesteckt hatte sich die
patienten wahrscheinlich in indien wo
sie wegen eines oberschenkelhalsbruch es
behandelt worden war
am ende starb sie an einer
blutvergiftung in einem krankenhaus im
us bundesstaat nevada
doch die neue mutation der bakterien ist
jetzt noch gefährlicher zitat die
krankheit schreitet schnell fort so chen
sie beginnt in den lungen und infiziert
dann andere organe wie die leber und
endet dann tödlich in den usa war es
eine rentnerin die an dem keim starb in
china sind mit etwas über 53 jahren
deutlich jüngere menschen gestorben
der neue erreger hat damit alle
eigenschaften eines super bazillus er
ist hoch infektiös graf junge und
gesunde menschen an und ist tödlich und
es geht schlag auf schlag am gleichen
tag erschien ein weiterer artikel der
kollegen und epidemiologen während chen
und barry white horse im magazin soll
ein zitat die untersuchung zeigt ein
alarmierendes revolutionäres ereignis
wenn wir seine ausbreitung nicht
schnellstmöglich stoppen kann es zu
einer globalen epidemie des antibiotika
resistenten und hochansteckenden erreger
scott der vollständigkeit halber es
soll in den usa ein medikament geben das
vielleicht gegen den erreger helfen
könnte allerdings ist es noch nicht auf
seine wirksamkeit getestet worden und es
muss auch bei einem ausbruch in riesigen
mengen hergestellt werden das ist also
alles noch ziemlich rum gewissen dass er
im moment der stand wir halten euch hier
natürlich auf dem laufenden
kein video zur entwicklung der krankheit
verpassen wollte und auch zu allen
weiteren themen dann und mehr hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den auf
die glocke denn nur dann werdet ihr auch
über die neuen videos informiert hier
geht es weiter mit den videos zur wohler
wenn ihr die entwicklung noch mal
verfolgen wollte das war absolut
dramatisch unbedingt drauf klicken dann
könnte ja auch die entwicklung in
diesem fall besser beurteilen und
ansonsten bislang bleibt dran